foreign
Steiner I'm a developer relations
engineer on the Chrome team at Google
today I want to talk about advanced apis
in real world apps
at previous events like last year's IO
you may have heard me and others talk
about project Fugu an effort to close
the web's capabilities and thereby
enabling new applications to run on the
web
talked about project Fugu before why
would we talk about the project again
well because there's been lots of
exciting stuff happening around the apis
that we've developed for a start you
will see how image editor photopia makes
working with files a supernatural flow
you will learn how blockbench adaptive
is used for creating the goats in
Minecraft enables users to pick colors
from anywhere on the screen
next you will see how the game editor
construct 3 makes sure you never lose
any of the games you create
and you will understand how the SVG
editor box your SVG lets a user pick any
of the fun staff installed locally
including Comics Sans MS
and last not least you will find out how
Adobe might zooming even the biggest
images in Photoshop a battery smooth
experience
before we begin this Epic Journey let's
briefly reflect back
as I said before the project Frugal
effort isn't new in November 2018 on the
chromium block we made a commitment to a
more capable web
in the blog post we promised to close
the gap
what Gap you may ask well the capability
gap between the things you can do on
platform specific apps and the things
you can do on the open web we work with
our partners and came up with a long
list of missing capabilities
for example in 2018 you could not edit
files on the web so we prioritized this
and many other use cases based on
partner and developer needs
we made our list of missing capabilities
public on our web tracker and label it
with project Fugu Fugu as the puffer
fish it's a delicacy if you cut it right
and can be dangerous if you cut it wrong
just like being able to edit an image
file on the web is fantastic but having
the power to delete a file that is
critical for the functioning of your
computer can have fatal consequences
by the way we don't allow system files
to be accessed from the web so
metaphorically speaking we make sure you
cut the fugu right so back to project
Fugu it's a cross-company effort in it
we have Samsung
and Microsoft and electron.js and of
course Google and Intel
Samsung makes a browser called Samsung
internet
and Microsoft is the maker of edge
and electron have less node libraries to
depend upon when they can just use the
web api's exposed by chromium Google as
you may recall has Chrome but
um
why is chipmaker Intel invested in
Project 4. Well turns out they looked at
what people are doing on Intel machines
and found out that they spent more than
60 percent of their time on the web
platform so there you have it that's
where Intel is a project partner all the
work of project Fugu happens in the open
for example you can look at our figure
API tracker where we keep track of the
shipped and then progress apis
actually recently I looked at this track
in detail which caused me to write an
article in which I ask is Project Fugu
done the when encountered we had shipped
55 apis ranging from web Bluetooth to
contact picker and from batting apis to
unadjusted movement pointer look
from webshare to app shortcut menu and
protocol handling to the forgetting of
Serial ports all the way down to web
custom formats on a clipboard 55 apis
that's a lot but as you might have
guessed we're not done yet
there's still plenty of use cases that
need unlocking and some of the apis need
refinement now that more developers use
them and boy developers do use our
Google apis we have a refreshed Showcase
of apps people have built with our apis
be sure to browse the Showcase add your
apps if they are missing and subscribe
to the RSS feed to be informed of new
apps with more developers using our apis
we've also identified a number of useful
patterns for doing so that we have added
to our patterns collection
they're all worth exploring but
specifically want to highlight our
Advanced apps patterns collection our
cool collection of clipboard patterns
and our fantastic collection of patterns
for working with files
I could go on and on and on since these
patterns are really really useful but
I'm supposed to be talking about
Advanced web apis in real world apps so
back to that
the first app we want to look at is
photo peer photopia is a free online
photo editor it has various image
editing tools including spot healing a
clone stamp healing brush and a patch
tool it supports layers channels
selections and much more it's on a
project for Google API showcase and if
you zoom in on its listing you can see
that the app uses a lot of fugu apis
every single one of them is interesting
but today I want to focus on photopia's
use of file handling file handling is
the capability of registering an
installed pwa as a file Handler with the
operating system foot up here is a photo
editor so logically it has registered
itself as a Handler for image formats
like jpeg this photopia installed I can
now right click a JPEG file and open it
with photopia
I could even go as far as promoting
photopia to the default file Handler and
open images with photo for the pr simply
by double click
so how did photo pure do this on this
slide you can see its production web app
manifest the highlighted section shows
the file handlers member which contains
an array of objects let's zoom in on one
each of these objects contain an action
key pointing at a URL and an accept key
pointing at an object with pairs of mime
types mapped to arrays of file extended
for example the mime Type image slash
PSD for Photoshop files is mapped to an
array with one entry the extension dot
PSD
photo pretices itself for 21 other image
related file types after decoratively
turning the operating system what file
formats photopia can handle the app
needs to imperatively do something with
the past files this is Minify production
code but it's easy enough to follow
it stores window.launch queue in a
variable called n and if it exists sets
its consumer to a function that gets
past the parameter w
this W has a property files by which the
past files are accessible
if you want to implement photo PS5
handling Behavior yourself check out the
how to handle files open from the file
explorer pattern
the file handling API is supported on
chromium-based browsers as a version
102. next I want to show you blockbench
blockbench is a low poly 3D model editor
if you have ever played Minecraft and
have encountered a goat you've met
something that was created with
blockbatch
bloodbench which uses UJS and 3GS puts
all the tools at your disposal to make
the creation process of low poly models
as easy as possible
you can use cuboids to get that
Minecraft aesthetic or create complex
low poly shapes using the mesh modeling
tools
you can create edit and paint texture
right inside the app and obviously it's
also contained in the project for API
showcase
similar to follow up here it uses
several football apis for blockbench I
want to highlight a small but neat API
called eyedropper
in this example I'm editing the texture
of a 3D model of a train
with bloodbines paint tool I can freely
modify the texture look what happens
when I click the Color Picker again a
magnifying glass that I can use to pick
screen colors from anywhere including
from outside the application so I can
pick the Lively Orange from the gorgeous
Mac OS Ventura background image
so how does this work pretty simple
here's the relevant snippet from
blockbence code base you initialize an
eyedropper by calling new eyedropper
then you just await the result of a call
to its open function which is an srgb
hex color string
for more details on how to work with the
eyedropper like blockbench see the
article picking colors of any pixel on
the screen with the eyedropper API
the eye dropper API is supported on
chromium-based browsers as a version 95.
you can talk about Minecraft codes and
not dream of becoming a game developer
guess what my next example may make this
dream come true
construct 3 is a fantastic web-based
game making software you can use it to
create anything from Platformers to
puzzles to racing games and much more
if you don't want to you don't even have
to touch code for your game
of course construct 3 isn't a project
for Google API showcase zooming in on
its card you can see it uses a ton of
Google apis
there's a lot to potentially dive into
but I want to put the emphasis on
construct 3's file system access here
I'm editing one of the examples poplab
on the screen here you can see that it
says Z to select let's change that to S
as in select
let me save my changes via menu save as
save a single file
let's call the file poplab.c3p
now contact 3 holds a reference to the
file which means I can just press
command plus s to save any further
changes to the same file without having
to go through a new save dialog every
time
but what's really cool is that when I
reload the app I can continue where I
left off
this works because construct 3 has a
stored serialized version of the file
handle into indexeddb
here I'll show you the code for saving a
file construct 3 calls it window.show
safe failpiper method it uses an ID of
save project file which a browser will
use to remember the working directory
with the types field the construct 3
developers give the user a hint about
the type of file via localized
description and via the accept field
tell the browser that construct 3 saves
its files via the mime type application
slash x dash construct 3- project using
the c3p file extension to learn how to
say first like concept 3 in a way that
works in all browsers check out the
aptly name pattern how to save a file
the first system access API Works in
chromium-based browsers as of version
86. other browsers can use a fallback
solution if you build a game you
alternate game assets some of these game
assets you might actually want to create
as a scalable Vector graphic SPG for
short boxy SVG is a great app for
editing and creating svgs boxy SVG is
built around the idea that user
interfaces should get out of the way
there's no crowded workspace with
overlapping dialogues and dozens of open
pallets and toolbars the illustration
takes the center of the stage
surprise surprise proxy SPG is in the
product Google API showcase
as the other app so far boxy SVG 2 uses
several football apis
especially interesting is the local font
access API
with boxy svg's text tool I can add text
to my drawing and a typography panel I
can choose the font for the text
boxy SVG integrates with the Google
fonts directory but thanks to the local
font access API I can also get access to
the fonts installed locally on my
computer
let's choose one of my favorite Classics
marker felt
the way this works is surprisingly
simple after feature detecting if query
local fence exists on window All That
Remains is actually calling the function
it returns a promise with an array of
the installed local font it's an
asynchronous function because if their
user hasn't granted access to their
fonts yet it will show a prompt asking
the user if they want to share their
fonts remember that the list of
installed fonts can be used as a
tracking Vector so you only want to give
it out when you trust the site if you
want to let your users pick their
locally installed fonts like boxy SVG
read the article use Advanced typography
with local fonts the API is supported on
chromium-based browsers as a version
103.
the last step we want to look at is
Photoshop the data we managed to get a
version of Photoshop running on the web
still blows my mind Photoshop is an
immigration and photo editing software
developed by Adobe
the tool provides many image editing
features for Pixel based raster Graphics
but also vector graphics for its UI it
makes heavy use of web components based
on lit
like all other tools mentioned so far it
too is contained in a project for Google
API showcase and as a powerful app it
obviously uses several different Google
apis I want to focus on adobe's use of
the origin private file system
the fat system standard introduces An
Origin private file system or opfs for
short as a storage endpoint private to
the origin of the page and not visible
to the user that provides optional
access to a special kind of file that is
highly optimized for performance
Photoshop uses files in the origin
private file system for the performance
zooming of images which is an expensive
operation
to make zooming as smooth as possible
Photoshop stores the image at different
pre-calculated Zoom levels in so-called
Maps as you can imagine whenever you
make a change to an image the maps need
updating as well Adobe really need it
the fastest possible way to get access
to files and this was through the origin
private file system
the full implementation details are of
course Adobe secret but using the opfs
Explorer extension for the Chrome Dev
tools you can peek under the hood a bit
and see how the sausage is made
the files in a temp folder that begin
with Photoshop are the matlabs you can
see that they get quite big and here I'm
only editing a small image but it's not
a secret though is how Photoshop gets
access to the origin private file system
they first obtain a root directory by
calling the asynchronous function
Navigator storage get directory next
they create a new file Handle by calling
the likewise asynchronous function get
file handle on the root directory
passing it the name of the desired file
and a Boolean flag called create that
says the file should be created if it
doesn't exist finally they obtain an
access Handle by calling create sync
access handle which is the last
asynchronous function in the chain all
other operations like write get size and
read Etc are then synchronous so though
we can access them without overhead from
M script which is what they have used to
Port Photoshop over to the web
to learn how to use the origin private
file system like Adobe read the article
the origin private file system
the origin private file system is
supported on chromium-based browsers as
of version 86 Firefox as a version 111
and Safari as a version 15.2
[Music]
wow five amazing apps that all useful
apis let's briefly recap what we've seen
we saw image editing app photopia and
how it uses the file handling API so for
API users can start editing images right
from their File Explorer we looked at
low poly 3D model editor blockbance use
of the eyedroper API so that the user
pick colors from anywhere on their
screen
we learned how Game editor construct 3
uses the file system access API to let
users save their Creations to disk and
enable a natural edit safe edit flow
the experienced how SVG added a boxy SVG
lets the users pick the fonts they have
locally installed on their computers and
finally we Dove a bit into how Photoshop
uses the origin private file system for
high performance access to metadata
files
another big question is what will we see
next what's the next amazing app that
you built with fugo apis remember to
check out the project focal API showcase
for inspiration
also definitely see how a collection of
amazing patterns to get you started in a
way that works on all browsers not just
Chrome
oh and just to be sure and avoid any
misunderstanding you can use football
apis from all Frameworks but with just
vanilla.js with that thank you very much
for watching I can't wait to see your
apps get attitude project photo API
showcase
[Music]